cosa fare per trasformare le città
a causa prima adesso riscaldamento
globale e vittime anche in qualche modo
in seguito alle inondazioni del
cambiamento climatico generato dal
momento della co2 che lecita producono
cosa fare per fare sì che le città
diventino protagoniste di una grande
grande campagna planetaria per ridurre
solo il cambiamento globale ma
innanzitutto essere consapevoli che
questa crisi pandemica non è una crisi
isolata ma che ha fortemente a che
vedere con la crisi climatica e dunque
la fragilità che questa situazione è
dovuta la pandemia ci ha trasmesso nata
agilità che dobbiamo sapere guardare in
faccia questa fragilità ci dice che la
dimensione dei fenomeni che non
conosciamo che non conosciamo di non
conoscere sia enormemente ampliato ma si
dice anche che dobbiamo smettere di
avere un rapporto di controllo
aggressivo nei confronti della natura la
natura non è più solo quello che noi
pensiamo debba stare fuori dalla città
fuori dalle case fuori dal nostro corpo
la natura si è dimostrata profondamente
interna alla vita della nostra specie è
un piccolo virus è stata capace di
costruire un sistema di osmosi
velocissimo tra tutti i membri di
individuo nostra specie sul pianeta
quindi dobbiamo in qualche modo
ribilanciare l'idea di città e di
metropoli in uno scenario completamente
diverso
facendo i conti con il cambiamento
climatico 99 ed è la prima il concetto
di ricciardi world park va estesa a
tutto il pianeta
noi dobbiamo creare ovunque dei corridoi
verdi che in qualche modo implementino
conserve da una biodiversità di specie
dunque aree protette foreste vanno
legati a città più verdi e questo
sistema che abbiamo visto creare con le
grandi in un'area verde in africa per
difendersi dalla estensione del sahara
che abbiamo visto in corso in cina nel
deserto
aveva portato in tutto il mondo grandi
corridoi planetari della biodiversità e
poi le metropoli metropoli devono
diventare metropoli transnazionali e ad
arcipelago io credo che il progetto che
abbiamo fatto quella croce ne è un
progetto da questo punto di vista
importante non è semplicemente
l'estensione del ginevra ma insieme ad
annecy non france si crea un sistema
all'arcipelago attorno a una montagna
quindi centro di questo è troppo
internazionale non è una piazza non è un
monumento non è un tempio non è una
sinagoga non è una chiesa non è uno
schema è una montagna della biodiversità
questo cerchio ripete il superficie
dell'acceleratore di particelle sferiche
di fornisce energia ma il concetto di
una metropoli internazionale a darci
quello che fondamentale una metropoli
dove il verde rappresenta il mare e dove
si colleghino le città e piccoli centri
in un modo logico dando sta ad ogni
cittadino la possibilità di accedere ai
servizi alla vita in un ambito massimo
di 15 20 minuti di tempo
questo porta con sé naturalmente io
della forestazione la prestazione nel
modo con cui i corridoi panetta
rientrano nell'arcipelago metropolitano
di verde ci aiuta innanzitutto pulisce
l'aria dalle polveri sottili che sono
una delle cause nella maggiore
diffusione del contagio in alcune zone
del mondo trasforma la co2 già prodotta
in ossigeno riduce il calore aumenta la
lega diversità riduce consumi energetici
quindi la forestazione un tema
fondamentale così come un altro tema
fondamentale quello della mobilità
dobbiamo imparare a muoverci non più con
delle auto in proprietà ma condividendo
uno stock di vettori privati che non
siano quelli che occupano in modo
estensivo le superfici delle nostre
strade quindi abbiamo bisogno di
rivoluzionare il concetto di mobilità e
devo dire anche da questo punto di vista
di immaginarci un rapporto diverso tra
le città e un rapporto diverso tra le
città e quel sistema
i piccoli centri rurali e storici che
costellano tutta europa tutte le aree
interne europee che dobbiamo imparare ad
abitare io credo che oggi grazie alla
grande e alfabetizzazione digitale
grazie al fatto che in qualche modo
abbiamo imparato come il lavoro sia
un'attività che segue il nostro corpo
grazie anche a modificarsi di alcuni
ritmi del lavoro settimanale non abbiamo
capito che si può pensare di rompere con
la tripartizione lavoro residenza tempo
libero su cui si è costruita la città
occidentale e immaginarci di dislocare
la vita urbana anche in centri esterni
evitando lo sprawl evitando quella
tragedia della città diffusa che ha
rovinato il territorio per i mari
abitando dei piccoli nuclei che erano
stati città nel passato che ci
garantisca un rapporto forte tra natura
e se connessi col digitale
se resi luoghi di comunità urbana
possono essere un elemento interessante
di alternativa di vita in contatto con
la città e grazie al sostegno delle
città a cui danno la repubblica la pro
potabile
il miglior cibo ed a cui devono ricevere
delle reti di sostegno della
distribuzione commerciale dei grandi
atenei degli al corte delle
multinazionali e da questo punto di
vista naturalmente alla cottura energia
devono diventare due elementi
fondamentali di un concetto di
autosufficienza le metropoli del futuro
devono essere metropoli che in qualche
modo grazie al fatto che ogni edificio è
in grado di captare energia rinnovabile
di conservare distribuito al suo interno
possono diventare realmente
autosufficienti così come un sistema
interessante intelligente variegato di
aree agricole e di zone trasformazione
dei prodotti vi con il cibo può essere
non solo una grande linfa per il mercato
del lavoro ma una presenza fondamentale
per garantire un concetto di sostanziale
autosufficienza tutto questo sta attorno
alle delle comunità le comunitari che
abbiamo bisogno sono comunità di vita
intensa di scambio
non possiamo pensare a modalità di vita
urbana che non
lo scambio tra diversi tra le culture
differenti al centro come diceva nel red
jacobs e le città sono fatte dalla
densità e dalla varietà è che io credo
che l'intensità sia il concetto chiave
abbiamo bisogno che le grandi metropoli
siano fatti di quartieri di bordi dove
c'è questa intensità di scambio così
come abbiamo bisogno che i borghi
storici ora ritornino ad essere le
piccole città dove c'è questa intensità
di scambio quindi questo è un rapporto
fondamentale e giù ruota intorno al
concetto di comunità ultime due
questioni sono da un lato la necessità
di poter riappropriarsi dello spazio
pubblico
c'è un tema legato alla progressiva
spostamento riduzione delle superfici a
parcheggio che oggi occupano una parte
sostanziale dello spazio pubblico spesso
in modo del tutto inutile e del recupero
di luoghi esterni quindi molto più
garantiti da un punto di vista nei
rischi di contagio legati al virus che
vengono trasmessi per via polmonare e
che devono diventare i luoghi della vita
il luogo della mente dove si estroverse
tutta quella dimensione di vite cose
viene all'interno dell'edificio scultura
commercio tempo libero lavoro sport e in
generale accompagnata questa versione un
altro processo fondamentale riguarda la
possibilità di rendere fluidi gli spazi
interni rompere la destinazione
funzionale immaginare spazio a geometrie
variabili gli uffici non saranno non
potranno più essere la somma di luoghi
di lavoro individuale però adesso nel
loro incontro perché il lavoro viene
svolto altrove così come le calli devono
poter diventare luoghi dove ci sono
opportunità per poter avere la
concentrazione giusta per poter lavorare
per poter incontrare le persone in
totale sicurezza quindi utilizzando i
tetti che sono un elemento fondamentale
del futuro dell'architettura dobbiamo
ridare i tetti una funzione
e pensare che i tetti possano essere
quello che
i cortili fino a qualche decennio fa o
che sono stati cortile nell'europa
dell'ottocento del novecento cioè luoghi
dove gli abitanti di un caseggiato ed è
un isolato lavoravano coltivavano
incontravano altri cittadini un luogo
caldo di interazione sociale
assolutamente sicure assolutamente
protetto dunque corridoi planetari della
biodiversità ma è troppo è troppo di
arcipelago in grado di inglobare grazie
alla forestazione urbana i sistemi della
natura vivente una mobilità leggera non
più basata sul concetto di proprietà di
soprattutto sostenibile che faccia
gradualmente rapidamente a meno del
carburante fossile una reciprocità tra
metropoli e reti di borghi rurali e
storici
l'idea di una comunità come luogo dove
la distanza dei corpi non incide mai
sull'intensità delle relazioni la
possibilità di straw vertere nello
spazio pubblico le funzioni collettive e
una grande fluidità degli spazi interni
questo è il futuro delle città